hey everybody it's the love doctor here
the romance Guru of the daily wire
Michael nolles and I've taken a deep
dive into short videos of real romantic
problems and triumphs and so now you and
I are going to sit here and watch me
watch videos of
[Music]
[Laughter]
romance what man hasn't been there what
man hasn't been in that
[Applause]
situation take a look at this nice break
and a little love tap on the 10 pin
Chris VI is feeding it out to that 4
five board down Lane and look at this
pin action
oh like that you talk too
much I I don't like that you gave me two
dads it's
confusing was that
staged even if it it's almost worse if
it was staged wow girls got a point
though pretty stupid pretty
stupid
IE all most of you now none of
you
take I'm I'm like not a nerd so I don't
even really know what that
means could not resist so I had to look
it up from the office of national
statistics from a 2019 study in ever
increasing numbers we are now at a
lesbian divorce rate of 72% so the top
four reasons that they are reporting
getting divorced is feeling ignored
inequality in the partnership adultery
and domestic violence personally I Feel
Like This lends some weight to men's
arguments and complaints about how women
are behaving in relationships because
when you have lesbian statistic lesbian
divorce statistics that look like that
the girls are kind of telling on
themselves yeah the lesbians are getting
divorced because they don't like men
anymore so they leave their husbands
right that makes sense to me I I
wouldn't I'd be surprised if the
lesbians were more likely to stay are
they is this lady referring to two women
together as a as a marriage or a divorce
it doesn't make any sense you can't do
that two ladies can't marry each other
that's the craziest thing I ever
heard come on man all right Matt truth
or
dare dare
um I dare you to call your
crush
what shoot I don't need I kind of don't
need to call my crush
cuz they're in this
car and oh
no
[Music]
no oh that's gross I assume that was a
joke oh gross oh God this is so
disgusting I think I'm going to
puke hey Henry
yeah how often do you think about the
Roman Empire what I said um how often do
you think about the Roman
Empire I don't know not that much
really I mean not more than the next guy
why he doesn't think about it more than
the next guy fact where am I would you
like to play a game a game r this baby
that ain't no game
like I don't know how I'm supposed to
feel about that actually I was only
kidding you can get the baby out of here
lifting is it gay wanting to impress
dudes more than chicks here's some hard
facts for you girls get dressed up to
impress other girls and guys get jacked
to impress other guys no guy gives a
about your $1,000 P that you stuff with
garbage and no chick gives a about your
vascular forearms that look like an
anime drawing of a monster
the only people who truly appreciate the
art of sculpting the male body are dudes
and we now know thanks to the dad B play
that girls will literally a ziplock bag
filled with gravy cuz it makes them feel
Superior so you ain't killing yourself
in the gym for them you do it for the
Bros and the gay guys do it with the
Bros it's a different show but it is the
same audience so I guess this one goes
in the center here yeah yeah sums it up
that's why I don't go to the gym ever
G what's a game makes me a super
straight I was in a town before called
um Langan Village it was called and
basically there was a young lad and he
looked awful similar to me I thought I
was fighting in the mirror right come
outside the nightclub I was like do I
know you from somewhere and he goes do I
know you do you know and he had he had a
Celtic jersey on but he had he had the
green and yellow one right and I was I
was about to throw punch and then he he
looked at me in the eyes and I go do I
he goes am I your father I said to him
he goes to me am I your son and we just
hugged it out turns out that no relation
at all and I just headbutted him and he
got taken away but you know it goes to
show you people are out there you could
know
them goes to show
baby of
kill and blood spilling that world never
came and
[Music]
they all right look I know women do this
and usually it's BS when they say that
but the other day I was at Costco and I
bought a ton of wine and I said we're
saving money and Alisa says to me she
says well no you're not you're spending
a lot of money and I said right but it's
25% off and so really I'm going to buy
the wine at some point you know
sometimes the women have a point who a
boy a girl what is it is
girl
you you knew what was going to happen
from the minute it started and it was
still very funny a girl came out to the
airport and just what order are you cuz
of Southwest and I looked up just
turquoise hair people with who dye their
hair I actually love it cuz like it's
nice to know like immediately I don't
want to talk to you does that make sense
oh my gosh okay that we like wouldn't
get along it's just like what
immediately I know we have nothing in
common right yeah it a good observation
I have nothing to add add to that oh
okay I just constantly was walking
around thinking people were just looking
at my ass no one likes being told that
they have a flat ass I've been there if
that makes you feel better no that
doesn't make me feel better it's just
hard even when you get mean comments it
doesn't mean you can take a whole week
off of work without telling anyone right
right it's just a new thing for me I
assume this is staged but I don't know
because of the time we live in I just
don't know
I identify as a Trans financial which
means that I'm a rich person trapped in
a poor person's buddy like ah
okay boo oh brother this guy stinks all
right that's our great romance
compilation see you next time I
just to
say I love
you